i've been deep in these documents
each of which is a piece of evidence
that helps me piece together
a very important question which is who
got rich off this 20-year war that we
fought in afghanistan
but first let me tell you what happened
on august 15 2021 the taliban had
entered kabul after taking over the
entire country of afghanistan the war
ended as it had begun with the taliban
in power once again
you probably remember the scenes from
the kabul airport total chaos as afghans
tried to flee their country but there's
one guy who saw a business opportunity
in all of this this guy eric prince
generously offered to help charter a
plane to evacuate people from kabul the
price tag six thousand five hundred
dollars per person that was the market
price that eric prince decided but this
wasn't the first time eric prince used
the war in afghanistan to get rich in
fact this was one of the last of many
instances where this guy profited off
the afghan war and some of the ways he
did it were kind of messed up so after
digging through the numbers the reports
the senate hearings all of it we've
established a list
of some of the top people who got crazy
stupid rich off of the war in
afghanistan on my orders the united
states military has begun strikes
against al qaeda terrorist training
camps and military installations of the
taliban regime in afghanistan
before we get into our list i want to
talk about an important term here which
is government contractor 300 million
dollars in government contracts u.s
defense contractor our broken system of
government contract at u.s federal
contractor registration we know that a
government contract is worth more than
the dollars awarded here in the united
states we love the free market
i'm talking about this
so instead of having the clunky old
federal government take care of all
things war we hire a lot of private
companies to do it for us this is
companies that make our weapons feed our
soldiers build our bases fuel our tanks
and literally fight our wars
yes we have private armies that we call
security companies
that basically are soldiers for hire
what this allows the government to do is
post a job out there like we need
someone to build a road in afghanistan
and in theory what happens is a bunch of
private companies come together and they
all bid on how much it would cost to
build this road and whatever company
gives the best price is chosen to go
build that road it's supposed to help
the government get the best price okay
so where am i going with this what i
want you to understand is that there is
this bidding process for private
companies to go do things that the
government needs but in wartime a lot of
those processes of bidding go out the
window because we're in wartime so it's
like an emergency so instead you get a
lot of situations where there is no
bidding on contracts the government
needs something done in afghanistan
really quickly this company can do it
name your price we'll give you whatever
you need as a client the us government
is guaranteed to have the funds to pay
you and will always pay you and it's
that very process
that allowed people to take advantage of
a system to let billions and billions of
unaccounted for dollars be poured into
private companies all of this
contributed to what a former secretary
of defense called a culture of endless
money inside the pentagon okay wait
before we go on i need to thank the
sponsor of today's video which is better
help
i've said this a bunch i'm going to keep
saying it which is that i'm a giant
supporter of therapy i think therapy is
something that
is stigmatized and specifically for me
maybe it's because i was a guy or
something i don't know but i never got
messaging that i was supposed to go to
therapy but i've been going to therapy
for two and a half years now and it has
truly changed my life better help is a
service that tries to make therapy more
accessible by connecting you
if you want therapy to a network of over
10 000 professionals and this isn't like
a crisis line or a self-help program
this is real licensed therapists giving
you therapy done securely over the
internet if you've ever looked for a
therapist you know that it's really hard
and the thing i respect most about
better help and the reason why i support
what they're doing is because they're
trying to make that an easier thing to
connect with a therapist if you don't
like the therapist you find you can
easily switch to a new one very easily
for free and betterhelp allows you to
connect with your therapist in between
your sessions to get a timely response
for whatever you're going through so i'm
a giant fan of betterhelp i appreciate
them sponsoring this video they're
giving you 10 off your first month if
you want to try it out there's a link in
my description clicking that link helps
support this channel and gets you
started on what could be a life-changing
thing i really really really support
therapy
so check it out thank you better help
for supporting this video for supporting
my channel let's dive back into the
video okay now that we understand
government contractors let's get to this
list of people who got rich
first up is robert stevens the former
ceo of a company called lockheed martin
it's a company that manufactures like
this helicopter the blackhawk they
manufacture missiles fighter jets bombs
they manufacture a lot of stuff that we
use in war this company gets a lot of
business from the pentagon like in 2020
alone this company got 75 billion
dollars worth of pentagon contracts i
know that like when we get into billions
it's really hard to like
know what that actually means but just
to put it in perspective the entire
budget of our foreign ministry the state
department totaled 44 billion dollars
for the entire state department all of
our diplomacy 44 billion
and lockheed martin alone this one
company got almost double that to make
our weapons 90
of lockheed's revenue comes from the
federal government their core business
the thing that keeps them afloat is war
and security so robert stevens became
the ceo in 2004 this was three years
into the war in afghanistan and as the
war intensified so did robert's wallet
and i know this because this is a public
company and all of the compensation for
executives is public knowledge to all of
us you may have to dig through some
boring documents like the lockheed
martin proxy statements from the 2000
annual meeting of stockholders on april
27 2000
but you can find it so let's see how
robert and his war business did in the
2000s so before the war in the late 90s
the ceo of lockheed martin was making
around 2 million a year if you include
his salary and bonus 2 million bucks
it's a pretty good compensation okay but
then the war started lockheed started to
get a ton of contracts started making
more weapons and look what happens to
the ceo's compensation his salary stays
about the same just over a million bucks
but his bonus now jumps up to 3.2
million dollars
bringing his total compensation to
around 5 million this guy's making 5
million bucks war is doing pretty good
for him not bad let's jump one year
later it's now 2006.
[Music]
and robert stevens the ceo of lockheed
martin brought in
18
million dollars wait what
from 2 million to 5 million to 18
million whoa robert stevens is doing
pretty darn good okay but let's keep
going the year after that robert stevens
brings in
30 million dollars in his compensation
30 million sorry 31 million
31 million dollars non-equity incentive
plan compensation 8 million
holy smokes
what 30 million dollars in compensation
i mean if we were to like graph that
the war starts here we're looking at
something like this this and this the
war was a life-changing event for robert
stevens the ceo of lockheed martin okay
so that's our first guy who got super
rich let's move on to the next one
[Music]
a guy named stephen orenstein this guy's
company called supreme group was chosen
in 2005 to feed u.s troops in
afghanistan to provide all the food i
mean when this guy got the contract i'm
sure the only thing that happened is
that his eyes started flashing with
money since he got the contract supreme
foods business increased 50-fold over
the course of six years the defense
department paid supreme 5.5 billion
dollars to deliver food to the troops
5.5 billion dollars and it became 90 of
his business 90 of his company was
providing food to troops in afghanistan
i mean talk about winning the lottery
but remember what i said about emergency
funding and contractors orenstein
realized that he could charge absurd
amounts of money for the meals that he
was providing to troops and he knew that
no one would notice because they were
just throwing money at this war the
government contracts just kept coming no
matter how pricey his meals were
[Music]
there's our beef ravioli
orenstein was like dude there's no
adults in the room like i'm a child in a
candy shop right now let's see how far i
can take this
not only was he charging insane prices
for meals but then
he started to create fake subcontracting
companies and started to win contracts
that were for nothing and the pentagon
would just pay him a ton of money for
doing no work and what did he do he just
pocketed the cash he got super super
rich off of this to the point where he
became a billionaire he got put on the
billionaire list or whatever but
eventually he took it way too far and he
got caught and yes we are now reading a
senate hearing from 2013 called
contracting to feed u.s troops in
afghanistan how did the u.s defense
department end up in a multi-billion
dollar billing dispute i don't recommend
you watch this hearing it's very boring
dla had paid supreme about three billion
dollars including 1.6 billion for food
and water and 1.4 billion for
transportation and storage costs the
numbers being thrown around in this
hearing are insane the pentagon overpaid
nearly 100 million dollars just in like
transportation costs which as one
congress person said that is an
astounding amount of money and then to
put it in perspective she says that that
amount would pay for nearly a hundred
thousand children to have access to a
head start program which is an early
education program in the us but instead
this taxpayer money went into
orenstein's pocket nice one stephen
think of the children come on so what
does it look like when someone gets
punished for this well here we are in
this senate hearing where the people who
gave all of this money without checking
where it was going are being questioned
and when they asked what happened they
say things like this
the contract management efforts that we
applied to this did not keep pace with
the changes that we were seeing in our
requirements let me translate that for
you what he was really saying is we
weren't really paying attention because
you know war according to this court
document stephen eventually did have to
pay up
389 million dollars
but let's be honest he got a little slap
on the wrist but
the guy got rich off the afghan war
which is why he's on this list next up
is this guy
eric prince this is the guy we talked
about at the beginning who was like
charging 6000 bucks to fly people out of
afghanistan i don't think any human
being
who has a heart and soul would support
efforts to profit off of people's agony
and pain as they're trying to depart a
country and fearing for their life he's
an ex-navy seal who inherited a bunch of
money and decided to start his own
private security company called
blackwater remember what i said private
security company really means soldiers
for hire this guy trained military and
police forces in fact he describes his
mission for blackwater as quote trying
to do for the national security
apparatus what fedex did for the postal
service privatize make more efficient
get rid of red tape etc etc kind of a
scary thought but okay he got his first
contract in 2000 it was a small contract
204 000
to help train the navy for terrorist
attacks then 911 happened an absolute
tragedy for the american people but an
incredible business opportunity for eric
prince and his
fedex for the army the us was desperate
to mobilize their troops for this new
kind of warfare so they turned to black
water to help them the u.s hired
blackwater to come protect their cia
compounds or to escort vip diplomats but
wait let's just get something clear what
are these guys are they troops or like
military
technically no they're not but they sure
look like troops i mean look at these
guys but really these guys are just like
fancy security guards that the
government hires and gives them security
clearances and sends them to war zones
so that they can operate like soldiers
under the jurisdiction of a private
company
but they're just security guards so
they're not like mercenaries or anything
right
by 2007 the government had given
blackwater over a billion dollars in
federal contracts let me repeat
this little company that provides a
private security force
went from meager contracts of 200 000 to
help train troops to sending troops
abroad to actually be in the war zone
and getting a billion dollars worth of
taxpayer money within just a few years
as you can imagine giving guns and
security clearances to a private army
might lead to some
thorny abuses of power and in fact in
2007 the guards of blackwater were in
iraq in addition to afghanistan and they
opened fire on unarmed civilians
indiscriminate shootings by blackwater
guards leading to the deaths of
civilians in a crowded public square
after a car bomb had exploded a mile
away they killed 17 iraqis and injured
20 more blackwater lost their contracts
it was a huge scandal and it was another
instance where there was some
accountability and yet eric prince sold
the company and came out on top another
guy who got really rich off the afghan
war oh and those security guards who
opened fire on innocent civilians were
tried and convicted
but then
wait for it
they were completely pardoned by donald
trump do we have any faith in humanity
next up we've got these two guys they're
nicknamed the war dogs there's a movie
about them that i haven't seen but i
want to sorry kind of an emergency sorry
don't worry i have to go first i'm
american but really the best thing out
there is this rolling stone article
these guys were ages 25 and 21 when they
started an ammunition company
they bid the pentagon and won 300
million dollars worth of taxpayer money
in contracts and they were going to
supply the afghan national army with
guns and ammunition i mean this is
insane these were like early 20 year old
kids one of these guys david was just a
few months earlier a massage therapist
and then was like i'm gonna have a
little change of career i'm gonna go
sell 300 million dollars worth of guns
and ammunition to the federal government
so they can fight a war in afghanistan
these guys got super rich off of this
and soon we're living a fancy life with
really nice cars and expensive
apartments in like miami but what they
were doing here was buying ammo from
china and then selling that to the us
government which is like a giant no-no
in arms like trading
they eventually got caught pleaded
guilty and one of them was sentenced to
jail for four years so this is a rare
case of like guys got rich and then they
got caught and they actually got
punished which didn't happen to supreme
food or eric prince the difference is
like when you're like a 24 year old kid
you don't have a lot of money and
influence so you can't like weasel your
way out of accountability but what this
story shows you is just how easy it was
to get in on this culture of endless
money within the pentagon the massage
therapist who had never owned a gun
before
started an ammunition and gun company
and got 300 million dollars for it just
like a gold rush okay so those are the
war dogs next up we have this guy fakim
hashimi one of the several afghan
nationals who got super rich part of
this group called the 911 millionaires
in the early days of the afghan war
there was huge need for local fixers and
translators the people who got in early
helping out u.s forces got really savvy
to how the u.s was operating and they
quickly realized that they could provide
a bunch more local services and make a
ton of money so fahim started a business
that eventually turned into like a media
corporation with like tv stations and a
construction company and even an airline
his company started racking in like 200
million dollars a year in government
contracts there were a bunch of afghans
who got super rich writing on the
coattails of all of this money being
poured into the country which it's like
good for them their country's been torn
apart by outside superpowers for decades
let them at least get something out of
it for heaven's sake next up we have
our very own congress
nancy pelosi and ted cruz aren't like
arms dealers but they can still get rich
off of war
[Music]
everything is gone god because if you're
a member of congress you can buy stocks
in defense companies like lockheed
martin and a lot of them do
at least 47 members of congress and
their spouses hold between 2 million and
6.7 million dollars worth of stocks in
top defense companies
oh and it's not partisan of the 36 house
members who hold stock in military
contracts 20 are republican and 16 are
democrats it's almost split in half i
mean let's get into the details here
like which of the congressmen have the
most money invested in defense companies
good question the winner for this year
of who's getting rich off war is kevin
hearn a republican from oklahoma who
owns over a million dollars in stock
from defense contractors 880 000
alone in honeywell which is an aerospace
contractor that congress really seems to
love and notice how well their stock has
done especially since 2009 when obama
sent a bunch of new troops to
afghanistan i mean this is a lawmaker
who has to give approval when we go to
war
and he stands to gain if we do but wait
the conflict of interest gets worse when
you look at somebody like senator gary
peters a democratic senator from
michigan who is a member of the armed
services committee which is the
committee that authorizes the pentagon's
budget
here's his financial disclosure
he's invested in a lot of things
including raytheon technology
corporation raytheon is a major
government contractor for wartime things
this guy gives money to the pentagon to
do war things with private contractors
and he has invested in the private
contractors in july this guy's committee
voted to increase defense spending by 24
billion dollars which is more than
president biden even proposed so in very
direct terms this guy is voting to put
more money in his pocket that is how our
system works here's another financial
disclosure of a senator who's on a
committee that deals with cyber security
and protection she holds stock in six
defense companies with most of her money
being invested in an it contractor do
you get it i t contractor that she has
invested in cyber security committee
that she uses to vote to give money to
the thing she's invested in it's just
like come on
okay so that's our list
and let me be clear that this is not the
exhaustive list of everyone who got rich
there are so many more people who got
rich there are so many more people who
abused the system we will never know
their names we will never hear about
them because they didn't get caught in
the end the pentagon spent 14 trillion
dollars 14 trillion dollars between 30
and 50 percent of that went to private
companies military contractors companies
that give huge payout huge compensation
to the top leaders that's like five
trillion dollars worth of taxpayer money
going to fat in the pockets of these
corporations and for what what did we
get we now know that it didn't do much
for this country and its people 20 years
later the country is falling back to
where it started but what it did do is
it made these people
really really really rich
good for them
okay i'm gonna go try to not be
depressed about how our democracy works
see ya
[Music]
[Music]